[Music]
i've asked you guys to send me these
clips and if i laugh you get paid
no that does not count i had 50. you get
50
whoa i didn't see what i was looking at
why did i shoot her
whoa
[Applause]
the horse getting hit got me i don't
know why that was funny
let's stop that cost me a hundred
dollars is that worth it felix no it
wasn't congrats gloria jessica
have been found to cause crushed
tracheas severe spinal damage and
violent decapitation
[Music]
god damn it god damn it i should have
seen that coming and i didn't
that's pretty good that plays games
congrats i always thought it was a cool
background i'm like oh my god 25 million
views well i got home today and
i swear i just saw a little kid smiling
at me
i was going crazy right
i know you can see the kids
[Laughter]
sometimes it's the simple things in life
man it's a simple oh you didn't leave
your email oh no money
no money
it's pretty good
i didn't laugh however i did not laugh i
don't care what you say i didn't laugh
just because i breathe does not mean
life
[Music]
well done champ oh [ __ ] they're smoking
no no
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
go ahead go ahead they're pushing hey
someone actually did that we know
they're here
it doesn't count because i've already
seen it
formal recruitment chair
we've been waiting for you all summer
[Applause]
oh yes that was great i'm not expecting
dark souls at it all right smooch and
bloom well done when whoever did that
god
[Laughter]
oh that's great
this is a swedish uh clip
it's called jerry speaks spanish i think
i've seen this
so there they have pen pals in school
and he has a pen pal with a spanish
person and he's talking about how fun he
was
to write the letter
it's me trying to speak
japanese i don't need you right hey
genki this oh god
[Music]
oh god
[Music]
the age of men is over
the time of hulk
ugh
yes
donate the team says okay sure
[Music]
no i will watch it again though
oh god doggie went gurp
a lot of you guys
don't want money apparently and i
appreciate that thank you welcome back
to sleepwalking
i put that [ __ ] on everything
no
that's not real stop
that's not
real i would have been funny if it was
real then you can take a small bite just
bite the corner like this
is it just buy it
gentle
it's so cute
i love that oh no paypal but shout out
to our advice oh god it's so funny
because egg you know egg gary well he
doesn't do that here let me let me
demonstrate actually okay hey
you can have banana
look a stupid face hey you can have
banana just a small bite okay mumbai
hey yo
come on small buy
do you have tea
okay i rest my case
what's wrong with cats
they can't realize there's nothing it
can do so it just screams
in agony
[Music]
that's awful guess they're so mean man
it's not cool man hey mom what's the
difference between a light bulb and a
pregnant woman
what jesse you can unscrew a light bulb
you like that a little too much come on
you can unscrew a light bulb
you know a lot of that's under 18 and
they don't use painful right well too
bad
children too bad
this is pinkie he's a male he's
available for adoption he's pet of the
week placer county animal shelter
he's a very loving cat i don't know
settle down bud
be careful
oh
[Applause]
oh
anyone want to adopt pinky they're very
loving cane well done frano
good job franna oh i need to smell you
don't worry come on up here
oh come on chair you hunk a lug over yes
all right it's just right up here oh
knucks
no
i don't even know why i left no please
please say it's for
damn it they left their email damn you
happy god damn it that's a stupid
there's no way ah are you seriously
watching porn by yourself nah i'm with
my let's go
sorry
thanks for sending that
don't make anything offensive chris
oh it's just a smelly face look at that
look at that little girl
it's too far man can't do that it's
gonna get age restricted to monetize
shadow bend hope it was worth it
all right fine control oh no
that's pretty good oh it's complete
you taped everything down nice
it's not too bad i kind of want to try
it
[Music]
it must feel so real playing it i wanted
to feel sniper recoil in the game
[Applause]
okay lame obviously
[Music]
[Applause]
that's pretty dope
kinda like it
[Applause]
still not enough okay
no
um bruh
[Applause]
it's pretty sick honestly all right that
was it for this um july if you lose if
you enjoyed in doing yes you could win a
billion next time subscribe a billion
like another billion and um
click another video for another billion
maybe you could
bye